Wayne is on Twitter at Dave Ramsey what
would happen to the economy if everyone
suddenly started your plan well the the
first thing if they suddenly the entire
population you can snap your fingers
stopped borrowing money it would crash
our economy because our economy has so
much banking and borrowing run it's
running through its veins however that's
a hypothetical philosophical question
that couldn't actually occur what could
actually occur and should actually occur
is gradually more and more people become
wise and decide to stop borrowing money
and so over a period of time we wouldn't
have as many banks and they wouldn't be
nearly as profitable the ones that
stayed open because it'd be less and
less people borrowing money you and I
know that there's never a case where the
hundred percent of the people would stop
borrowing money that's impossible
even prohibition 100 percent of people
didn't quit drinking you know I mean
it's just it's impossible to get a
hundred percent of people doing anything
so but we're talking about more reality
than theory here so reality is is that
if we can move more and more people away
from debt what would happen well more
and more people would prosper as
individuals as families because the less
if you don't have debt you have more
money to give more money to invest so
charities and ministries nonprofits
would be better funded by ten or a
hundred acts as people move away from
debt because giving and generosity
increases when people are debt-free
savings and investing would increase as
people are debt-free which means wealth
would increase among individuals and so
you could slow down some of the
disparity between the richest and the
poorest
this thing that everybody's worried
about wealth inequality and all the
lefties are all freaking out about
wealth inequality wealth inequality
wealth inequality I would start to go
away
because one of the things that magnifies
that exponentially is the the haves are
building wealth and the have-nots are
building debt and so it's it's making
the poor poorer and the rich richer
because the rich aren't in that and
they're they're becoming wealthier and
wealthier in a lot of cases that's how
they became wealthy the millionaire
theme our confirms that and so what
would how the other thing that would
happen is debt has destabilized the
economy made it more volatile because
everyone's living on the edge
living on the bubble every time there's
a little wave that comes through
something that scares people just a
little bit it crashes entire segments of
the culture but if a wave comes through
and you got a really nice boat you just
kind of smile and ride the wave meaning
that you don't have any debt and you
have a big emergency fund and the
economy slowed down a little bit it
doesn't cause you to slow down oh and by
the way business would prosper and there
would be more jobs what well let's think
about it if you if you just think about
your life and your home if you are a
hundred percent debt-free mortgage and
everything and you had an emergency fund
and you were making good money do you
spend more money yes you do well you
spend on clothes nicer clothes vacations
even go out to eat you save more and you
give more because you have more but you
also spend more because you have more I
spend more now than I ever have at any
time in my life but I have more than I
have any time in my life I mean let's
pretend you had five million dollar net
worth
and you had this zero debt and you had
$100,000 your income you would be
spending more and so where do you think
you're spending that you're spending the
local restaurant so if more people did
that more people spent the local
restaurant what would happen at the
local restaurant well it would prosper
what would happen in the local hardware
store would prosper so the overall
economy would prosper
yay even explode because spending would
increase but when spending increase
based only on consumer confidence that
causes the consumer to falsely be
confident and therefore go and borrow
money that further destabilize of the
economy even though it gives a
short-term spike to the economy because
when the consumer gets all cocky and is
willing to go put money on credit card
debt and willing to go buy a car they
can't afford and put it on payments and
willing to go buy furniture they can't
afford to put it on payments because
they feel so good about everything that
drives the economy up let's all borrowed
money and what goes up must come down
when it's borrowed but if it goes up and
it's you're spending money that you
actually have and a whole bunch of
people did that simultaneously over a
10-year period of time the economy would
boom all of that to say that this debt
economy at the federal level with the
federal government borrowing like
they're drunk I mean like they're stoned
and you borrowing like you're drunk like
you're stoned
on cars and student loans and furniture
and vacations and all this you drive the
economy when you're doing that but
you're falsely driving it because it's
it's a it's a shell game it's a house of
cards and it's going to come down what
goes up must come down when it has to do
with debt but if all of that the
spending was done with real money
meaning not borrowed money you would see
the economy increase you would see
prosperity increase you'd see individual
wealth increasing you would see
charitable giving increasing this is
what would happen if people move towards
God's ways of handling money which by
this is not my plan this is God's and
grandmas ways of handling money live on
less than you make live on a plan don't
do get-rich-quick avoid debt have money
saved to buy things have money saved for
emergencies have money saved to retire
own have money saved to send your kid to
college get out of debt this is all in
the Bible it's all in your grandma's
common sense so it's not my plan it's
God's and grandma's ways of handling
money it's common sense and biblical
finance and it works so if we could
gradually get people to take steps that
way if you could just get your whole
church to do it it changes your whole
church which by the way whole churches
are doing it it's called the momentum
series where they take 80% or more of
their church through Financial Peace
University if you can just get a whole
town to do it if you could get a segment
of the population to do it a certain
people group a minority yeah a region
you would see that group prosper that's
the answer to your question Wayne well
what happened to the economy of everyone
suddenly started doing your plan it's
not my plan it's God's and grandma's
ways of handling money and they can't do
it suddenly everybody at once because
nobody wants does sudden anything
suddenly not 300 million people but
gradually over the period of a decade
what would happen would be increased
prosperity the same thing that happens
to individual households when they get
on a written plan called a budget so
that they get out of debt so that they
can save and invest so that they can be
outrageously generous and have a higher
quality life and become wealthy
that is the plan and I don't know why
it's it's not appealing to everyone I
don't understand why would you do that
you don't want to win really why
wouldn't you do that because there's
children out there in adult bodies
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good one
definition of maturity is learning to
delay pleasure it would require that the
culture become more emotionally and
spiritually mature and we're going the
other direction actually so I've still
got work to do
never fear we're here this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]